MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Most people who
are familiar with paying
for things probably know
what an invoice looks like.
But you may also be aware of how
challenging deciphering a Cloud
invoice can be, potentially
with thousands of lines
of cryptic acronyms and text.
On this episode and
"Beyond Your Bill,"
we'll walk you through how
to explore your costs using
Google Cloud Billing Reports.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Our last videos
covered how resources in your
GCP account can be organized
and how to manage permissions
with a billing account.
In this video, we'll
look at how you
can explore the costs associated
with a billing account
by viewing billing reports
in the Google Cloud console.
We'll focus on answering
some common questions
like how much am I spending,
what are my cost trends,
and what are my cost drivers?
I'll use a sample billing
account for this video,
but you can go to
the Cloud console
and use the left hand navigation
to click on Billing and then
Reports to view billing reports
for your own billing accounts
and projects.
The report defaults to
the current calendar month
and shows you a lot of
information right off the bat.
In the top left,
you can see the cost
to date for the
current month and how
that compares to the
cost for the same time
period in the previous month.
In the top right, you can
see the forecasted cost
for the current
month and how that
compares to the cost
from the previous month.
Right in the middle,
there's a chart that
shows cost group by project.
Each color shows a
different project,
and you can hover over the chart
to see more specific details.
There's also a dotted
cost trend line
that forecasts what
you're spending
might look like in the future
based on historical trends.
Under the chart,
you'll see a list
of projects and a table view.
In addition, there are
filters on the right side
to drill down and further
analyze your costs.
You can customize the time
range you're currently
viewing so you can
explore previous months,
the past quarter, or any
other window of time.
In addition, you can
toggle the invoice month
to line up the report
directly to your invoice.
When looking at your
costs by invoice,
you'll be able to filter out
specific charges such as taxes.
This is the best way to get
an exact visual representation
of the invoices
sent to your company
and to explore the costs
associated with each project
or service.
You can also choose
from other filters
to see how your
costs are trending.
As you change the
time range, the costs
and comparative
costs above the graph
will update based on your view.
You're also able to
filter costs by location,
selecting a geography,
region, or multi-region area.
This is especially handy to
see a cost breakdown by region,
such as comparing your costs
between the Americas and EMEA.
Click a location to include
it in your filtered view
and deselect all the locations
to go back to the default view.
There is also the ability
to selectively filter out
credits, which can be made
up of different discounts
based on your usage, such
as sustained use discounts
and committed use discounts.
For example, if you have a lot
of consistent compute engine
usage, you may see a big impact
from sustained use discounts.
Sometimes you need to
drill in to see what's
driving a spike in your cost.
In this particular
billing account,
we can see that some pretty big
spikes have occurred recently.
By hovering over the chart, it
looks like one specific project
is responsible.
The next step is
to drill in further
to understand what caused it.
We'll filter to just the
specific project responsible
and then group byproduct
to see more information.
Having a consistent and
clear naming convention
comes in handy here so
that you can track down
the right information
about the project usage.
For our example, it looks
like a rise in BigQuery usage
is responsible for the spike,
but we can see even more detail
if we filter by SKU.
This reveals that
BigQuery analysis
is what's causing the increase,
which is the SKU for running
queries in BigQuery.
With the GCB project and
specific cause outlined,
it should be a lot
easier to narrow down
what action or application
is driving the cost.
So the billing reports
let you see your costs
and drill down
into specific areas
to monitor and investigate
unexpected changes in cost.
If you're just looking
for a high level
summary of your costs, try
the cost breakdown report,
which you can also access
from the left hand menu
from a billing account.
This report lets you see how
discounts and taxes combined
with your usage costs to arrive
at your final invoice amount
every month.
Using these
different reports can
show you a clear picture of your
costs for different scenarios.
Using the billing
reports available to you
directly within the
console, you can
see what you're
currently spending,
visualize the amount
your forecasted to spend,
and understand
your cost drivers.
In the next video,
we'll look at how
to export your billing
data for further analysis
and create custom dashboards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]